when gas prices are so high right now we
know it impacts you it affects us as
well so we've started a campaign in
cooperation with conoco to help gift you
a good day let's take a look at how i
surprised one lucky conoco customer and
gifted her a good day
[Music]
i met shirelle at conico near mountain's
edge because prices are so high she
doesn't always fill her tank
i'll go like fifty dollars here and then
it'll run out in a few days and i have
to come back and i can hear you've got a
youngin in there how how hard is it to
have a youngin to have things cost more
and just try and get through the day
it's it's really hard it's been really
hard for me and my family honestly
because it's almost like it's another
bill i know it's a bill but it's a
higher bill now that's when i decided to
gift her a good day channel 8 and conoco
we are gifting people good days here so
we're going to try and help you but
we're gifting a good day we're going to
help pay for your gas this morning oh my
god really thank you so much you're
welcome oh thank you so much i'm gonna
use plus
[Music]
you hear that she's using his plus for
her car now that she's got the money out
i had a great time surprising sherell
and her young child who was
sort of willing to be a part of this you
never know where you could be next so
keep an eye on
us around the valley